all right well after the utter disaster
in afghanistan president biden could
soon be facing another foreign policy
crisis the president facing off with
vladimir putin in a high-stakes virtual
summit over fears russia could invade
ukraine but not exactly striking fear
into the heart of the russian leader
with moments like this
good to see you again
i uh
unfortunately
last time i said we didn't get to see
one of the g20 i hope next time we meet
we do it in person
right now there's a massive buildup of
russian forces along the border between
those two countries and the u.s has been
threatening to slap russia with economic
sanctions if putin invades so harold the
white house keeps saying that putin
hasn't made a decision yet
do you think that's true
well i i don't know what i do know is we
should all be rooting for him the
president in this instance here we had a
we had a pull out in afghanistan uh that
didn't go as well as we wanted i don't
think i think we could all agree that
could have gone a lot better i think the
white house would as well i think putin
is does not want ukraine in the in in
nato for for all the obvious reasons
that means that nato would come to the
defense in support of them but i thought
the president today did what did what he
had to do uh and i think he probably did
it more effectively than than we thought
look what putin can't have is the
oligarchs attack and attack being
economic attacks
and the kinds of threats that we're
making to put the economic clutch around
him is pretty doggone strong because if
putin is not necessarily afraid of
voters in russia he is afraid of the
oligarchs but if you have the voters in
russia concerned about the
how their economic output is and
economic productivity and you have the
oligarchs concerned about their
resources i think that's the pinch you
have to put on him for him to want to
change and to get that smirk off his
face which he always has when he talks
with our president so dana sanctions
have failed uh on russia before they now
have the nordstrom 2 pipeline jake
sullivan the white house security
advisor today national security advisor
tried to argue that pipeline is actually
leveraged for the west
and not for russia yeah i found that
curious because the pipeline's not like
a toy you can take away from a child
because they were being naughty that
pipeline has been being built for years
and one of the things i was going to say
is that putin and lavrov the foreign
minister basically they've been through
many administrations they're super
patient they've been through
clinton and bush and
and
obama and trump and they're looking to
buy it and they're like
they're they're very patient
what what putin really what what he
really wants is ukraine back but
he might settle for ukraine not getting
into nato right now right and after i
bet i bet he gets that yeah betty gets
that and then so then you have to ask
them well then what else is left right
if he's starting to get that you wait
until just a few more years and if you
then nordstrom 2 is underway the gas is
flowing into germany i think germany is
going to vote for ukraine to be in nato
no i don't i don't believe that
so
there there are a lot of geopolitical
concerns i believe here because if a
sovereign country can have two other
countries makes decisions for
it like meaning that the united states
and russia are basically
dealing with ukraine and ukraine can't
do that what does that mean for all
sorts of other countries in the world
and i and we focus a lot on china and
taiwan but there are others all across
the world
where we're not going to send troops and
really truly to me the only real
deterrence if you're not going to do the
swift transaction piece for russia would
be
show of force and i don't think biden's
going to do that yeah jesse when biden
was vice president president obama sent
the ukrainians some blankets uh when
russia was threatening to invade and
after they went into crimea to try and
defend themselves so it's not that this
is just a russia thing china's watching
this when it comes to moves that they
want to be making
did he do a good dropship well he's
distracted from china with what putin's
trying to play with ukraine and that's
kind of annoying because you know we
should be looking at the pacific but so
they've surrounded ukraine and if they
want to invade and conquer ukraine they
can but it's going to be so brutal and
so bloody and so costly for the russians
that it's going to really almost destroy
that country so dana talked about it
we've been playing a game with ukraine
we dangle
nato membership over ukraine to like
screw with putin's head
and it destabilizes him he's kind of off
balance because they need ukraine out of
nato but we play this dance because we
don't really want ukraine and nato it's
an indefensible country it's just flat
they just roll right through it so we
don't want it but we pretend like we
want it and it just makes putin go crazy
and he does all this crazy stuff so i
just think you just sell javelins to the
ukrainians just give them as many
javelins as possible they just take
these tanks out like that they're great
and then you tell putin we're not going
to buy any oil
stuff it and then bolster security in
the baltics but just keep your eye on
the pacific don't let this distract you
from the chinese do you think sanctions
could work you know jackson don't always
work but in the package of stuff i i
just say let's load up the ukrainians
with javelins do you think we should
load up the ukrainians with javelins too
tyrus i wouldn't send troops there i
think we should send tyrus there listen
i would only say
i've gone to russia uh three times i'm
actually the first wwe match in the
history of russia i'm very proud of that
but i was also out there when georgia
got invaded so not a good time
here's the thing uh i think that putin
he sees the lay of the land
and he saw he sees how the woke
administration makes deals
i'm sure he gave the taliban a call and
they're like so what did you get how
many helicopters how many wow hey
new training exercise let's all go stand
by ukraine and see what we can get and i
guarantee you he's going to get a lot
they're not going to get nato
they're not going to get any new weapons
he he'll get some new deal there'll be
some new thing
and
it'll act like it's a victory and
ukraine's going to be like what about us
just like who are you corinne the people
at the airport in afghanistan were
saying what about us the dinner bell has
been wrong and
everybody's coming to get a piece just
gonna say putin holds all the cards and
all the leverage
so
one word what should we do should we
send troops if no because what putin
doesn't want is us having military
conducting military exercises there in
ukraine i i mean i'm against putin but i
understand what he wants so a deal has
got it providing defense
providing weapons that might be very
helpful but the other thing is remember
that people in ukraine who fight in the
military they're they're like your
physical therapist who and now he's like
now he's got to go and fight for his
country and russia they're professional
soldiers i mean it's hard to imagine
what would happen if he said you know
what because of this they're in nato now
what well because
that would be well if we could do that
unilaterally maybe we would but you have
to get consensus and germany is like no
yeah i don't want to protect that
country group work hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else